[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be doing
something a little bit different
we're going to be discussing the aspects
of love and relationships in harry
potter
throughout the series we see various
romances blossom
they have their highs and they have
their lows and then all of a sudden
the story just sort of ends in today's
video i'm going to be discussing the
relationships
that became solidified after the book's
films
ended we see some relationships become
solidified
during the story like remus and tonks
but others are left a little open-ended
i think that some of these are obvious
but a few of them are a little less
obvious
so i'm curious to see if you know them
all fortunately
rowling expanded on the harry potter
universe after the story had ended
so we can indeed confirm that these
matchups are canonically consistent
number eight
george weasley and angelina johnson
that's right
george weasley of the fred and george
weasley duo ended up marrying angelina
johnson
later angelina weasley as we know george
and fred were the closest of brothers
and they shared a beautiful friendship
where they would spend every waking
moment with one another
as you can imagine after the loss of his
brother and twin
george was a bit lost the wizarding
world had ended and peace had returned
but he now faced a new struggle life
without his brother
however as we know life must go on and
so he focused on his work
becoming quite successful however over
time
george began to develop a relationship
with a fellow gryffindor graduate
by the name of angelina johnson angelina
johnson was a witch
born in 1977 she played a reasonably
active role in the series
becoming a member of dumbledore's army
and also captaining the gryffindor
quidditch team in her seventh year which
was also
harry's fifth year george and angelina
ended up getting married and having
children
but the unusual thing about their
relationship is that angelina was
actually fred's ex
i'm not sure what the rules are
surrounding tasting your dead twins
ex-girlfriend
but it certainly sparked some
controversy with fans
to make things slightly more unusual one
of their children was called fred
fred ii and their daughter was named
roxanne
number seven ron weasley and hermione
granger moving on to another weasley
now this one is certainly more obvious
and it's even included in the epilogue
however since then even more information
has been revealed about their
relationship
so i wanted to give you everything that
i know starting right at the beginning
ron and hermione were butting heads they
drove each other mad
constantly hurled insults at one another
and had more than one falling out
however they always came back to each
other and as they grew older the mutual
unspoken attraction became more and more
prevalent
what many might not realize however that
ron started developing these feelings of
affection
as early as the second book when he
became irritated by her crush
on gilderoy lockhart in the fourth book
their romantic feelings really began
building up
and by the time the sixth book rolled
around it was undeniable
who were they kidding after the war
ended ron and hermione got together and
had two children
rose and hugo oddly enough after the
series ended rowling
expressed that she regretted putting
them together breaking the hearts of
many fans
she even remarked they would likely need
some marriage counselling
maybe harry was the mediator they always
needed to make it work
oh maybe she and ron will be all right
with a bit of counselling
you know i wonder what happens at wizard
marriage counselling
they'll probably be fine he needs to
work on his self-esteem issues and she
needs to work on being a little less
critical
number six luna lovegood and rolf
scamander after the war ended luna
lovegood ended up becoming quite a
famous young magisterologist
staying true to her love of magical
creatures for those unfamiliar with the
profession
a major zoologist is a wizard or witch
who studies magical creatures
one of the most notable major zoologists
in harry potter
is newt scamander who wrote fantastic
beasts and where to find them
and interestingly enough luna actually
went on to marry
rolf scamander newt's grandson rolfe was
a british wizard that worked for the
daily prophet
and became a magisterologist himself it
has been expressed that for their
wedding
luna dressed in typical eccentric lunar
fashion
sporting a rainbow dress and tiara with
unicorn horns
later on sometime between the years 2008
and 2014
the pair had two sons lawson and
lysander
some fans were upset by this news as
many speculated that luna and neville
would have been a good pair
however rowling had different plans for
neville number five
neville longbottom and hannah abbott
this is an interesting one that sort of
comes out of left field
neville and hannah are never really
shown as being intimate with one another
to add to this they were in different
houses hannah was a half-blood witch
that began studying at hogwarts in the
same year
as neville but she ended up in
hufflepuff we of course know that
neville was a gryffindor
however there are a few connections that
can be made between the two
that potentially serve as reasons for
them inevitably ending up together
first of all both of them were in
dumbledore's army so they had that going
for them
next they shared herbology lessons
together this was made possible because
gryffindor and hufflepuff students
shared this class in their year neville
excelled at hypology
which probably meant that his
environment led to a more charismatic
confident neville one that can send an
arrow from cupid's bow
into the heart of a young hannah abbott
furthermore in the battle of hogwarts
neville was an absolute stud so he
likely impressed
many female sutras the pair never ended
up having children
as far as we know but we do know that
they moved in together above the leaky
cauldron
where hannah worked as a landlady as i
mentioned above
many were upset that he didn't end up
with luna but i guess it just wasn't
meant to be
number four draco malfoy and astoria
greengrass
that's right even draco malfoy found
love in the form of a story of green
grass
draco is mentioned a little bit in the
epilogue but we don't get
much information so i'm here to expand
on things
while attending hogwarts draco never
seemed to express much interest in the
opposite sex
however many speculated pansy parkinson
a fellow slytherin
would have been a perfect pairing for
young draco however
that never came to fruition and instead
draco ended up marrying astoria
greengrass
a girl that was two years below him at
hogwarts unfortunately
draco's parents didn't think
particularly highly of the pairing
as per pottermore draco married the
younger sister for fellow slytherin
astoria greengrass who had gone through
a similar
though less violent and frightening
conversion from pureblood ideals
to a more tolerant life view was felt by
narcissa and lucius to be something of a
disappointment as a daughter-in-law
they had high hopes of a girl whose
family featured on the sacred 28
but as historia refused to raise their
grandson scorpius in the belief that
muggles were scum
family gatherings were often fraught
with tension as mentioned above
the bear had a child scorpius malfoy who
attended hogwarts at the same time
as albus severus potter in a tragic turn
of events astoria actually ended up
dying quite young
falling victim to a blood-borne family
curse this left draco
a single father number three harry and
ginny
another obvious one but again there
might be some things that you don't know
jk rowling discusses harry's
relationship with ginny further
the plan was which i really hope i
fulfilled is that the reader
like harry would gradually discover
ginny as pretty much the ideal girl for
harry
she's tough not in an unpleasant way but
she's gutsy
he needs to be with someone who can
stand the demands of being with harry
potter
because he's a scary boyfriend in a lot
of ways he's a marked man
i think she's funny and i think that
she's very warm and compassionate
these are all things that harry requires
in his ideal woman
at first it seemed like harry and ginny
would never be able to happen ginny was
his best friend's sister
harry didn't know what to make of ginny
at first but after the events of the
chamber of secrets
he began to see her as more than just
his friend's little sister
and instead her own confident young
person however
at this stage he certainly didn't have
romantic feelings for her
in 1996 however all of that changed
harry's relationship with cho had
recently fallen to pieces
and harry began spending a considerable
amount of time with ginny
at the burrow over the summer in his
first potions class with slughorn
the love potion and watenshire revealed
he was attracted
to something flowery he had smelled at
the burrow this smell
later turned out to be the smell of
ginny's hair furthermore after
witnessing her kissing dean thomas
harry started to feel jealousy
confirming that he did in fact have
feelings for her
shortly after this time period the pair
shared a subtle romance
and even exchanged a few kisses however
it wasn't until
after the war that things really picked
up eventually the pair got married and
had three children
lily luna albus severus and james sirius
number two percy weasley and audrey ah
another weasley that's right even percy
the difficult weasley ended up finding
happiness and love
in the form of a witch named audrey
whose maiden name we don't know
in fact very little is known about the
relationship of percy and audrey
but we do know that they had some
children their two daughters were named
molly
and lucy number one bellatrix the
strange and voldemort
this is a weird one and while their
intimacy was revealed after the series
ended
they technically must have gotten
together during the series
and we know this because of their
daughter delfini she was conceived
sometime in the mid to late 1990s in
secret at the malfoy manor
and her birth did actually coincide with
the events of the original books
we just never had any indication of it
though bellatrix was a notorious mass
murderer she did have a soft spot for
the man that she served
lord voldemort this was obvious but
what's less obvious is that voldemort
shared some kind of
mutual attraction my own personal theory
is that bellatrix use a love potion on
voldemort
and if you want to hear more about that
check out the video link which i'll
leave at the bottom of the description
their relationship obviously falls into
cursed child territory
which i know a lot of you don't
appreciate so you can take this
relationship however you want and that's
it for this video
did you learn something about love in a
wizarding world comment down below
until next time remember differences of
habit
language nothing at all if our aims are
identical
and our hearts are open
you